[Musique]
c'est notre nouvelle maîtrise
mademoiselle choisi vous êtes en retard
et chez votre premier jour je suis
mademoiselle j'ose y allez prenez votre
livre de mathématiques
il m'appelle je mange un bout de craie
et je vole alors ce que vous êtes une
super maîtresse
[Musique]
hu
volley
[Musique]
oh
comme les eaux
faut vraiment que je travaille
l'atterrissage
la nouvelle directrice va enlever
d'autres animaux ce soir pour les
revendre je dois y aller maintenant dans
ce cas on vous accompagner tout c'est
beaucoup trop dangereux
j'y vais seul
[Musique]
qu'est ce que cette sans merci
mademoiselle pour ce spectacle mais la
fin de la récré bien sonnés là
y'a quoi là dedans pour se laisser ça
peut a fait recours des sports etc votre
tenue de sport
[Musique]
tu arrives même comprendre avec ses
oreilles bizarrement ça bizarre
[Musique]